Prof: Okay,
let's get going.
This first slide really is just
an update on the content of my
lecture last time,
and it actually has two
messages;
there's the direct message and
then there's the meta-message.
Andrea interpreted my lecture
last time as me making the claim
that parents usually don't
intervene in fights between
their offspring.
And so she had this nice paper
that she'd read on hyenas that
showed that actually mother
hyenas do intervene in the
squabbles between the baby
hyenas,
and that they do so probably
because in some seasons they're
actually able to get enough
food--
if there are twins born,
say that are sisters,
that are fighting with each
other in the first week of
life--
to actually rear both of them.
And that's an important
qualification.
So I want you all to know about
it.
But the meta-message is this.
I really appreciate being
informed about things like this.
I have to cover an incredibly
broad range of biology in this
course, and I can't read all of
the latest literature in all of
it.
And so if any of you feel
moved, by the work that you have
done on your papers,
to increase my knowledge by
sending in a little qualifier on
one of my lectures,
I would be delighted to receive
it;
then my lectures next time
around will be a little bit more
current.
So.
Student:  Can you check
your microphone?
Is it on or off?
Prof: Open to all kinds
of criticism.
>
Okay, today we're going to talk
about alternative breeding
strategies.
And I asked Alex actually to
come up with one of his
incredibly neat videos today,
and he had trouble on YouTube,
and other places,
finding a really neat video of
alternative breeding strategies,
in males.
You'll see some slides.
They are dramatic,
and they really are all focused
around one basic idea,
and I just want to show-
indicate that at the beginning.
And it's actually in the
simplest example,
in the bullfrog example.
Okay?
And the whole issue of having
an alternative breeding strategy
revolves around frequency
dependence.
So the usual scenario is that
at some point in the
evolutionary past a male has
achieved a dominant mating
status,
and that sexual selection has
then driven the evolution of his
behavior and his morphology--
the mating system,
polygeny, polyandry,
whatever;
in which case it would be a
female who would achieve the
dominant mating status--
so that there was a focal pair,
and that that biology got
pushed to a certain degree.
But once it evolved,
it created the opportunity for
alternatives.
And so that's the theme of the
whole lecture;
okay, it's alternative ways of
getting a mating.
And as you'll see there are
quite a few issues that are
interesting, and it covers a
pretty broad range of different
kinds of organisms.
So this is the paradigmatic
example.
And this often happens in
various kinds of frogs,
not just bullfrogs,
that the male calls,
the female hears the male
calling, moves toward the pond,
and the male will then grasp
the female with incredibly
strong forearms.
And if any of you are
interested in frogs,
or had one in your pocket,
you may have noticed that males
have different forearms than
females.
They really have Popeye the
Sailorman, bulked up,
steroid forearms,
and once they get onto a female
it's actually extremely hard to
pry them off.
You might be two hundred times
their weight,
but boy they are hard to get
off, and that's because that's
where all of their reproductive
success is.
If they can stay locked onto
her when she releases her eggs,
they will get the babies.
Of course what then happens is
that a small male will jump on,
on top of the large male.
If a small male gets onto the
female first,
the large male will grab both
of them and practically squeeze
the small male to death.
Now the point of this is that
the behavior of the dominant
male,
and the female who's attracted
to him,
created the opportunity for the
alternative behavior of the
small male.
If that hadn't already been
there, the alterative wouldn't
exist.
In the spring in the meadow
that was behind our house in
Switzerland,
when the male frogs started
calling in the pond in our
neighbor's garden,
and the females started coming
down through the meadow,
the male frogs that were
waiting for the females to move
by would jump onto them,
and then the females would have
to carry those guys on their
backs,
around 100 meters,
to get to the pond;
during which time,
you know, other frogs would be
trying to jump on.
So it's a very--part of the
intensity of this is driven by
the ephemerality of the pond.
If it weren't the case that the
pond was only going to be there
for a little while,
and only really suitable for
raising baby frogs for a little
while,
it wouldn't be so intense.
But that's the case,
and it is incredibly intense.
It all happens in a period of
about twenty-four to forty-eight
hours.
Now a similar kind of
alternative--well similar in the
abstract sense;
a similar alternative mating
strategy has evolved in figs and
fig wasps.
And figs and fig wasps are one
of the wonders of ecology and
evolution.
There are--I don't want to be
precise because in fact I don't
think we really know.
But let's say there are more
than 500 species of figs in the
world--many of them in tropical
rainforests;
many of them critical
ecological resources providing
food throughout seasons when
other trees are not providing
food--
and each one of these species
of figs,
in general, has its own fig
wasp, and if it didn't have that
fig wasp,
it couldn't get pollinated.
So what's going on here is that
the figs are sacrificing some of
their own seeds to raise the
wasps that pollinate them.
And this clearly has evolved
from an ancestral situation in
which the wasps were actually
parasitizing the figs,
and ripping them off,
but now has evolved into a
mutualistic and very complicated
mutualistic relationship.
The strategies of both the figs
and the wasps vary.
You'll see in a minute that
sometimes the figs are
monoecious, sometimes they're
diecious;
in other words,
sometimes they are producing
fruits that only have male
flowers or only have female
flowers,
and sometimes they're producing
fruits that have both kinds of
flowers in the same fruit.
And the wasps have really
highly differentiated strategies
that depend on whether they're
copulating inside the fig,
outside the fig,
and so forth,
and sometimes you get both
kinds of strategies in the same
species of wasp.
So here's a fig,
and here are some of the wasps
that would be living on it.
And this is about how big they
are.
Okay?
So they're pretty small.
And in fact if you've gone to a
nice organic store,
and you have eaten figs from a
there is a certain probability
that you've increased your
protein intake,
and you probably haven't even
noticed.
Now, the figs can make either
long or short styled flowers.
And what that means is that
they are making flowers which
are going to be targeted by fig
wasps, or not targeted by fig
wasps, for their babies.
And if we--if you work through
this diagram,
you'll see that the figs that
have long styled flowers are
going to be getting pollinated,
and there aren't going to be
any larvae developing on them.
These are the ones that are
going to make new figs.
Okay?
And the figs that make short
styled flowers are going to be
chosen--in this species of fig;
this isn't for all,
but this is for one of the 600
species of figs--
they will be chosen by the wasp
that will oviposit in them,
and the wasps will eclose.
They will mate;
in many cases they will mate
inside the fig,
and then when the females leave
the fig,
the timing of the fig's flower
maturation is such that as the
females force their way out of a
narrow aperture,
there are flowers bearing
pollen right next to that
aperture on the inside,
and the female takes them out,
and then she flies off to
oviposit in another fig,
which is how the pollination is
achieved.
So they had to set up two
separate ways of making seeds;
the ones that the wasps would
use and the ones that would make
future figs.
Other fig species have
partitioned this in other ways.
Okay?
So there's an interesting
complexity of evolution that's
gone on in this relationship.
Now the alternative mating
strategies are that there will
be fighting males or dispersing
males.
You don't need to pay too much
attention to this;
this just shows that the more
winged males there are,
the more females get mated by a
winged male, that's all.
But there is a frequency
dependent thing going on inside
one of those figs,
as the males are hatching out.
If they fight with each other
and kill each other,
then the survivor will be the
only male who is in that fig,
or one of the few males in that
fig,
who can mate with the females
that are coming out.
So there is--you know,
if you commit to that strategy,
you are committing to an
extremely aggressive,
live by the sword die by the
sword,
kind of existence,
and it all gets carried out in
a dark little fig,
and you're just waiting for the
first female to hatch out so
that you can mate with her,
and you get as many as you can,
and then you never fly,
because you don't have any
wings.
You die in the fig.
So that's your protein intake;
it's dead males.
On the other hand a certain
number of the females are going
to manage to get out of the fig
without being mated inside,
and if you can go out and find
them,
outside, then you don't have to
commit to fighting.
However, there are very strong
morphological tradeoffs between
the two kinds of things.
You can't do both well;
so you're committing to doing
one or the other well.
And how much each pays depends
on the local biology.
How likely is it that the
female will be able to get out
of a seed,
an eclose, and get her wings
ready to go,
and get out of there before one
of these fighting males comes
over and gets her?
So that's what creates the
frequency dependence.
And you can see these things
are radically morphologically
different from one another.
This is a case in which the
alternative reproductive tactics
are really resulting in changes
that you could just pick up by
looking at the things.
You might need a hand glass to
see it very clearly,
because these guys are down
about one millimeter long.
But it has resulted in major
morphological change.
And, by the way,
these, from an evo-devo
perspective, this is neat
because all of these forms are
elicited essentially from the
same genotype.
These guys are haploid;
these are the males.
This is the female;
she's diploid.
Otherwise they have the same
genotype,
and these alternatives here are
probably being determined just
by one autosomal locus with two
alleles,
that are determining whether or
not you are a type that flies
out of the nest or stays in the
nest and fights.
And you can see that the female
is equipped with really a
beautiful, exquisitely long
ovipositor to get her egg into
the fig seed.
Okay.
So we've seen that bullfrogs
and fig wasps--the bullfrog
biology is relatively
straightforward;
the fig wasp biology is almost
arbitrarily complex.
But they both create situations
in which alternative male mating
tactics are possible.
And the thing that drives that
is that there is a very well
developed,
evolved, prior biology,
that means an alternative has
an opportunity to insinuate
itself.
You can think of the
alternatives as being parasites
on the prior condition.
Now, there is probably no group
of organisms in which the
diversity of mating tactics and
parental styles has been more
broadly and diversely developed
than in fish.
If you're interested in this
stuff, the fish hold more
material for investigation than
practically any other group.
A survey of alternate male
mating tactics in fish came up
with these kinds of definitions,
and I want to run through them
for a moment,
just so you have those words
clear in your head.
So there are three different
kinds of parasitic male
reproductive behaviors.
So the sneakers are using speed
or stealth to get access to a
spawning.
So they don't necessarily look
like a female.
They just kind of hang back,
let the spawning start,
and then they whip in.
The female mimics actually
deceive the territorial or
guarding males into thinking
that they are something to mate
with,
and then a female comes in and
when she spawns the female
mimics then reveal their true
colors and release sperm,
rather than eggs;
surprise, surprise.
And the pirate males are males
that steal fertilization by
being big bullies.
So they let some other guy do
all the work of cleaning a
territory and setting up a nest
and going through all of the
trouble of displaying and
attracting a female,
and then just as she arrives
they whip in,
and because they're bigger and
tougher they push him out.
So that's a pirate.
Okay?
Now there are also cooperative
male reproductive behaviors.
Satellite males can display and
can contribute to territorial
defense and parental care.
And so we don't have to view
this as strictly a short-term,
selfish kind of exploitation.
There can be cooperative mating
going on,
and it will stabilize if it's
really win-win,
so that everybody in it is
winning something from the
interaction.
So if you just look at these
morphologies,
the satellites,
the sneakers and the mimics are
usually lacking sexually
selected ornaments,
and the guards and the pirates
usually have such ornaments.
Okay?
So the pirates kind of look
like the guards.
They're not so much
morphologically differentiated
as they are behaviorally
differentiated.
This is a phylogenetic
distribution of these
alternative reproductive
tactics.
And the white is group spawning;
the grey is mate
monopolization,
with no alternatives reported;
the stripes are an equivocal,
unresolved ancestral state;
and the black ones are the
alternative male reproductive
tactics.
Now you can see that there have
been quite a few.
I can read off--you can't
probably see all of this,
but those are cyprinids there;
some of those have alternative
tactics.
Some gobies have alternative
The wrasses here are in the
Labridae.
But there are some alternative
reproductive tactics in the
cichlids and so forth.
You can see--the interesting
thing,
and the take-home point from
that picture is hey,
fish do a lot of different
things, and they have
independently converged on
alternative male reproductive
tactics multiple times;
which you can see from the fact
that the black is spottily
distributed across the
phylogenetic tree.
Now if you go through that tree
and you analyze it--we assume
that we're usually starting from
mate monopolization;
so a guarding male and one
female.
And then you ask yourself,
well what happens from that?
And it looks like out of that
ancestral state there has been
some evolution of group
spawning,
and there's been some
transition from that back
through mate monopolization.
There seems to have been some
move from group spawning
directly over to alternative
reproductive tactics.
And if we take a closer look at
where you go into alternative
reproductive tactics,
it looks like the most frequent
one is that sneakers pop up.
That seems to be the easiest,
at least the most frequent
evolutionary transition.
And from sneakers,
or from mate monopolization,
you can get female mimics;
you can get satellite males.
So this is the cooperative one.
And then the pirates are not so
common.
So I'm going to step through a
case which is pretty well
analyzed.
It's in one way more
complicated than the simple
situation, and in another way,
in terms of the kinds of things
you can measure,
rather simple.
So this is a wrasse that lives
in the Mediterranean,
and Suzanne Alonzo,
in this department,
studied it for her Ph.D.
thesis and her post-doc.
And Suzanne gave me these
slides.
It is a case in which the
nesting males are providing
parental care;
so the guarding males,
if you like.
They are the ones that build
the nest.
There are smaller non-nesting
males that come in and sneak
spawns.
A nest takes about ten days.
So you can go out and get a
pretty good sample.
You can fly over to Corsica,
put on your wetsuit,
get in the water,
stay there for three months,
you're going to go through a
whole bunch of nesting cycles.
About one-third of all nests
are deserted,
and they can be deserted either
because there's an
intra-specific or an
inter-specific interaction.
And it is the females that
choose spawning situations.
Okay?
They're not really choosing
males or territories;
they're choosing to go into a
situation in which they see one
male, many males,
a certain kind of general
topography, that kind of thing.
So this is Suzanne.
This is a male on his nest,
and he is nesting in algae.
Okay?
So this is a big mat of algae,
and he has cleared out a hole
in it.
This is a female,
and the nest is below her.
By the way, these guys are
about that big.
And here's a bunch of female
mimics.
And often if you go to a
nesting site you will see oh
anywhere from two to ten of
these, hanging around.
So one of the questions you can
ask yourself--and this is where
Suzanne used evolutionary game
theory in kind of a simple way;
it's pretty much a cost-benefit
analysis--should you guard or
should you sneak?
In other words,
should you invest your energy
in guarding your nest and in
guarding your female,
or should you try to increase
your sperm production?
Okay?
So that's the basic assumption.
Either it's guarding or it's
sperm production.
If you guard,
one assumes that's decreasing
the risk of sperm competition.
If you do get into the sperm
production racket,
then it's thought to be a fair
lottery,
which means that the
probability of a fertilization
is just directly proportional to
what frequency your sperm are in
the pool of sperm that's being
produced.
And these fish have external
fertilization,
so you can pretty much estimate
that by analyzing a sample of a
cloud of sperm produced at a
spawning.
The guarding males don't know
if they're in sperm competition,
because the female mimics look
like females.
Okay?
So the male is guarding and he
thinks he may have a number of
females around him,
and it's hard for him to know
whether they're females or not.
That's not true of the female
mimics;
they know that they're going to
be in sperm competition.
So this just gives you an
example of how a behavioral
ecologist would think about that
problem.
Okay?
You do a Cartesian reduction,
you break it down into its
elements,
and you write down what would
be your reproductive success if
you were guarding mates.
Well there would be some risk
of sperm competition.
There would be the amount of
sperm that you as the guarder
produced per mating.
There would be the sperm from
other males.
Just this is the assumption of
equal frequency.
Okay?
So this is the proportion of
eggs you'll get if you do that,
and this is the probability of
no sperm competition over here.
So that's your reproductive
success.
If there's no sperm
competition, you'll get them
all.
If there is sperm competition,
you'll get this proportion.
And if you look at it--if
you're allocating the sperm
production,
which is what you might be
concentrating on if you were a
sneaker,
well this would be your risk;
proportion fertilized,
probability of no sperm
competition and so forth.
Okay?
So basically if you're a
guarder, and you're considering
the allocation within your own
body to these two possibilities,
you just ask,
"When am I going to get
more out of guarding than I am
going to get out of sperm
production?"
And that simplifies to this;
which is that the relative cost
of mate guarding has got to be
smaller than the relative cost
of sperm production.
So that's the--I just--this is
presented actually not to have
you try to write down equations,
or replicate them,
or think that they're going to
be on the test.
It is presented to show you
that when you approach a new
problem you use very simple
logic,
and you try to keep it as
simple as you can,
and you just try to see if
there might be any surprises
that arise from using very
simple logic.
And I hope that that is a
motivating comment,
because you can actually get
quite far in these circumstances
just by using very simple logic.
You don't have to think that
scientific research is based on
things that are so technically
obtuse that you won't be able to
see through them.
So to get back to our fish,
back from the algebra to the
fish, the nesting males don't
know if they'll be in sperm
competition.
The female mimics know they're
always going to be in sperm
competition.
And the fertilization rates are
about 100%.
So the nesting males are able
to reduce their risk of sperm
competition through mate
guarding.
And there really is evidence.
This is the proportion of
spawns that are snuck;
this is the number of mimicking
males at the nest.
And the number of--if you just
go out there,
you know, with your mask and
snorkel,
and you're writing down how
many males are at the nest,
what this kind of work does is
it tells you that the number of
males that you see at the nest
actually is a rough predictor of
the amount of sperm competition,
which is going on.
And the proportion of spawns
which are actually successfully
snuck does increase with the
number of mimicking males at the
nest.
Okay, so what's going on with
sperm competition?
Well this is sperm per spawn,
times a million.
And if there's just--and
you--by the way,
the way that you do this is you
watch the spawn,
and you go down there with a
sampling device,
which is a plastic tube,
that will take in a liter or so
of water,
and you put the mouth into the
middle of the spawn,
and you suck in a sample,
and then you take it back,
spin it down and analyze it.
So that's how you get the data.
If a pair is spawning,
the male has produced
relatively little sperm,
and if there are sneakers that
are going in--
so this is a pair plus one
sneaker--
this is the additional amount
of sperm that he is putting into
the spawning.
So he has obviously taken
advantage of the fact that he
doesn't have to put energy into
guarding, and he has allocated
that into spawning.
However, because of the
behavior and the dominance of
the guarding male,
who is larger,
he is usually able to get
closer to the female,
and in fact he is actually
getting more offspring out of
his 1.5 million sperm than the
sneaker is out of his
approximately 5 million sperm.
So these males are actually
getting well paid by investing
in guarding, rather than
allocating the sperm.
And the model is predicting
that mate guarding should lead
to higher success;
that's by an analysis that
actually includes more data than
I have put up here.
So the sneakers are essentially
males that are making the best
of a bad job,
and they suffer from high
variance in mating success.
So they try,
and they go from one male to
another, and they try repeatedly
over the course of the season.
And the percentage of eggs
they're able to fertilize is
going up and down a lot with
each spawning;
whereas the guarding males are
getting less variance and a
better geometric mean of total
eggs fertilized throughout the
spawning season.
Now that's an interesting view
of the world,
and I think that it's the basic
view of the world that comes out
of almost every analysis of
frequency dependence using game
theory.
It is a world in which there
isn't an optimal solution.
It's a world in which there are
losers.
It's a world in which there is
conflict.
And certainly this is a mating
system in which long-term
conflict is always going to be
there,
and it's basically because the
more guarders there are,
the more opportunities there
are for sneakers;
and the more sneakers there
are, the lower the mating
success of sneakers is going to
be.
So they will always be
maintained at intermediate
frequency and they'll never go
away.
It's a nice habitat.
The water is pretty clear.
It's fairly chilly.
It's about 18 to 20 degrees
Centigrade.
So it's not the warmest place
in the world to work,
but it's good clear water for
observation.
Now one of the interesting
parts of behavioral ecology that
has received a lot of emphasis
in the last- increasingly in the
last twenty years is the
behavioral ecology of gametes.
So what's actually going on
when we consider the alternative
tactics of sperm,
or the alternative tactics of
eggs,
and can we actually see
alternative tactics reflected at
the level of the sperm,
as well as the level of the
adult?
And this is a case in which we
can.
So the sperm that are produced
by males that are adopting
different tactics actually have
different swimming speeds.
So the open circles are pirates;
the boxes are territorial males;
the sneakers are these filled
dots;
and the triangles are satellite
males.
And this is a cichlid fish from
Lake Tanganyika that broods in
shells, and has this range of
alternative male behaviors.
And if you look at how fast the
sperm can swim,
they have, in the first minute,
they all have better swimming
speeds than after about a minute
or so.
So what happens is they go
through their energy stores
really quickly--
it's like that first minute is
really important,
so they all sprint for a
minute--but then the sneakers
manage to hang on better over
the next five or six minutes.
So this is an interesting case
where the whole organism,
alternative morphology and
behavior,
is associated with a syndrome
at the gamete level of changes
in swimming speed.
This hasn't been much
investigated,
and my guess is that there's a
lot more stuff like this going
on than we already know about.
Well how about other fish?
Well a lot of the things that
you're probably familiar with
happen to be species in which
alternative male reproductive
tactics are well described.
One of the classic ones is the
bluegill sunfish,
and another are the West Coast
salmon.
So this is male bluegill,
and this is a male Coho.
And these numbers here are
actually years.
Okay?
So the bluegill is a fairly
long-lived sunfish,
and the female is born and
matures at- grows up and matures
at about four years,
and then has probably about
another three to four years of
reproductive life.
The male makes a decision after
say late in its first year.
So if it's born say in June,
then a year later,
in August or September,
the male is making a decision
either to become a sneaker and a
female mimic,
or to commit to growing for
another five years before it
will mature into the dominant
guarding male form.
Now these are pictures of
what's going on.
The bluegills like,
by the way, most centrarchids,
dig a nest and deposit- and the
male is going to be guarding
eggs that are deposited there.
And the sneaker will come in
and basically come into a
breeding assemblage,
and actually get in between the
male and the female,
while the eggs and sperms are
being released.
He actually pushes in between
them, he's sandwiched in between
them when he releases his own
sperm.
In West Coast salmon,
which are genus
Oncorhynchus,
Pacific salmon,
the difference in size is even
more dramatic,
and the difference in life
history is huge.
So again in the summer of,
you know,
following say the first
birthday, the male is making a
decision either to stay at home
in the stream,
or go to sea.
And let me remind you that
salmon are anadromous they run
up streams to spawn.
They lay their eggs into well
aerated gravel reds in the
spring, in the stream.
When they hatch out,
depending on the species,
they either spend a little time
or a lot of time in fresh water.
Many of them go to sea.
And what they get by going to
sea--which by the way is a very
risky thing to do;
it's dangerous;
you run a gauntlet of predators
going downstream;
you get out into the North
Pacific and you have to deal
with seals and killer whales and
all kinds of things that want to
eat you while you're growing up;
and you may very well swim 3000
miles out of a river anywhere
from California to Alaska,
out into the Gulf of Alaska.
What you get for that is rapid
growth.
You can eat all kinds of stuff
in the ocean that's not
available in fresh water.
So you take a huge mortality
risk to get the benefit of
growing large.
Then when you come back,
the female will basically make
a nest in the stream.
They have fantastic homing
ability.
It has been calculated that a
salmon say swimming up the
Fraser River,
or the Columbia,
and it's smelling the different
tributaries that are coming into
the river,
it can detect a difference of
one molecule concentration
between its left and its right
nostril.
So it will tack the right way,
going up stream,
to get into the particular
ground where it's going to make
this nest.
And when it makes the nest,
you have a fish which is
probably about this big,
which is tossing boulders,
which are about this big,
out of the way,
to dig out its nest and
excavate a place where it can
lay its eggs.
And in comes a male,
who has gone out to sea and
weathered all of those
tribulations and whatnot,
and he is coming home to spawn.
And lurking there on the
sidelines are these guys that
never went to the ocean.
They're tiny,
weenie little guys.
They never took the risk,
but they run in and sneak a
spawning.
Okay?
This is the size difference,
on the spawning ground.
And the eggs are released and
they fall down into the gravel,
and actually the insemination
is going to go on down in the
gravel.
So it's not as though this is
something that's easy to
control.
Doubtless, if you are an adult
ocean going male,
you are a bit irritated to have
these little whippersnappers
there stealing your matings from
you.
But they're so small that they
can actually go down and hide in
the gravel.
So, in fact,
it's a stable polymorphism.
Both--the female would never
actually release her eggs if
there weren't a big guarding
male there.
These little guys just don't
elicit that kind of reaction
from her.
So his presence is creating
this opportunity for them.
Okay?
Now it turns out that there are
sneakers and guarders also in
dung beetles;
you know, just go across the
entire Tree of Life and you will
find almost every chink in a
mating system being exploited.
So if you look across sixteen
different species of dung
beetles,
that have sneakers,
you can document that the
sneakers have larger testes,
and that sneaker frequency
actually influenced male
expenditure on ejaculate.
So this is a case in which the
guarding males can see that
there's a sneaker there,
and if there is a sneaker
there, they up the amount that
they put into the ejaculate.
So there is a flexible local
response that's triggered by
this.
This is one such species.
Now why is it that I've been
talking about males?
Why haven't I been talking
about females?
Student: Is it because
the males are usually the ones
that left.
Prof: Usually they are.
And so in what kind of a mating
system do you think you might
have the potential for the
evolution of an alternative
female reproductive strategy?
Student: Well poly--
Prof: Yes, polyandry.
Something like this.
This is a pair;
this is a male and a female
jacana.
They are in the Amazon.
My wife took the picture,
from the front of a Zodiac.
And she's got about four or
five of these guys,
that she's guarding.
So she has a territory that's
about an acre,
on which four or five males are
sitting on eggs,
and she is defending all of
them.
And you can see that her
fighting spurs here on her wings
are a bit larger than the
male's, and she takes the lead
in defense.
So she actually charged the
Zodiac and tried to drive off a
boat that was 1000 times her
weight.
In this kind of a situation you
might think that an alternative
female reproductive tactic could
evolve.
In fact, polyandry is so rare
in the animal world that there's
very little evidence for it.
But certainly abstractly that's
the sort of situation in which
it could occur.
The other naturally is more
cultural.
That would be in the harems of
the great dynasties;
lots of alternative female
reproductive tactics there.
So the main issues that we see
in alternative breeding
strategies are first this idea
of frequency dependence.
And if there's anything you
remember, you know,
from this lecture,
when you're fifty-years-old,
this is it.
Okay?
It's that once you get a
guarding male and a female well
evolved,
they then form a focus for
further evolution that creates
the opportunity for a frequency
dependent minority behavior,
like sneaking or pirates or
female mimics.
The condition dependence of
this is well established;
and let me talk about that for
a minute.
Several times I have mentioned
with the fish that it's in the
late summer,
right after their first
birthday, that they're making a
decision to go one way or
another.
That decision,
whether you're going to grow
up,
develop into a guarder or into
a sneaker or a female mimic,
is often determined by your
condition at that point.
Have you been able to grow fast
or are you growing slowly?
And if you are at the upper end
of your growth cohort,
if you're one of the really
good growers,
you probably commit,
if you're a salmon,
to going to sea;
if you are a bluegill sunfish
to growing up,
spending another five years to
become a guarder;
and if you're at the lower end
of that, you will commit to
becoming a female mimic or a
sneaker.
And it's important to see that
that's a condition-dependent
strategy, and it can depend on a
lot of things.
It doesn't necessarily depend
just on the genetic quality of
that particular individual;
it can depend on the growth
history, the local environment,
anything that's going to lead
to either a rapid or a slow
growth curve.
So condition-dependence in
these situations is well
established.
Female choice is often an open
issue.
You might think that females
might want to favor one or the
other of two male morphs,
but in fact I think if you
think about it for a minute,
there may not be much reason
for female choice.
Can anybody tell me why there
might not be?
There you are, you're a female.
You've got thousands of years
of evolutionary history to
inform your decisions.
You see the guarder and the
sneaker.
Should you prefer one?
Yes Blake?
Student: Super male is
more successful and manages to
fertilize her eggs,
since they're more fit,
and you want your sons to have
that >.
Prof: That's right.
But what happens in the
frequency dependence of the two?
What happens to the frequency
of the two morphs,
the sneakers and the guarders?
Let's suppose they're at
evolutionary equilibrium.
What's the relative fitness?
They'll be equal.
So if you're looking at two
guys that actually because of
the frequency dependent process
have come to an evolutionary
equilibrium,
and you're scratching your head
and trying to decide,
should I make a choice between
them?
The answer is evolution doesn't
care.
Those guys are going to give
you the same number of
grandchildren.
That's another factor that
stabilizes this interaction.
It's not just the fact that
males are competing with each
other;
it's that once their
competition has come to an
equilibrium, there isn't any
reason for the females to prefer
one over the other.
They're going to get the same
number of grandchildren out of
both.
Yes?
Student: But if the
female is more prepared and
>
with really big males,
and the females will only spawn
when they see one of those,
not when they see the small
guys.
Prof: The females,
remember, have an evolutionary
history of having started out in
that situation,
and so the lack of female
preference is probably more that
they're not chasing away the
sneakers.
And they do,
by the way, want to get their
eggs into a nest.
Right?
And only the guarder is going
to do that for them.
So in that sense they have to
prefer the guarder because he'll
take care of their eggs.
But when they're actually in
the mating situation,
and they have the option of
going five inches to the left or
five inches to the right,
and they can see that they're
surrounded by a guarder and a
bunch of sneakers,
they don't--in that situation
they don't care.
Because their eggs are going to
get into that guarder's nests,
whether they're fertilized by
the guarder or by the sneaker.
But I take your point,
they do have to get the eggs
into a guarder's nest.
So sperm adaptations are quite
interesting, and they're
increasingly well understood.
There is a growing literature
on gamete evolution,
and it turns out that gamete
evolution can be quite
complicated.
I think some of you have run
into the concept of Kamikaze
sperm or sperm that themselves
have split up into different
tactics in the female
reproductive tract,
and things like that.
That's an interesting thing to
look into.
So that's it for today.
And next time is the last
lecture, and I'm going to talk
about selfishness,
altruism and cooperation.